وسيله نعم بدايه ساقوم مضطره للحديث بهدوء
وبصوت منخفض كي لا اؤثر على عمليات العد
التي تستمر هنا في هذه الغرفه التي نتواجد
فيها تم اغلاق باب الدخول اليها بطاولات
للمراقبين مراقبون من
التحالفين تحالف الشعب او تحالف الجمهوري
يراقبنا بجديه بالغه في الحقيقه عمليات
العد بدايه لم يبدا الفرز بعد نحن الان
امامك عد من شاركوا في القوائم ايضا عد
الاوراق التي لم يتم استخدامها في هذه
اللحظه يتم عدل الاوراق الانتخابيه التي
لم تستخدم وهذا سيؤثر بطبيعه الحال على
نسبه المشاركه نحن نعرف ان المواطنين
الاتراك يتوجهون الى دوائر محدده بمعنى ان
كل شخص يتوجه الى صندوق محدد يتوجه الى
غرفه محدده في مراكز الاقتراع هذه الاوراق
التي يتم عددها الان هي اوراق غير مستخدمه
في الصندوق بجوار هذه الاوراق اغلق بعد
انتهاء عمليات العد سيبدا الفرز وكما قلت
لك وسيله ان المراقبين من كلا التحالفين
يراقبون هذه العمليه في هذه الاثناء بعد
ذلك وسيله سندخل في تمام الساعه السادسه
بحسب التوقيت المحلي في تركيا في عمليه
حظر قانوني تفرضها الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات وهي التي تشرف على كافه
التفاصيل المرتبطه بالعمليات بالانتخاب
بالعمليات الاستحقاقات الانتخابيه في
تركيا وحين اقول هنا الحظر هو الذي يتعلق
بعدم اصدار اي نتائج الا بعد ان ترفع
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات حظرها احيانا
تخرق بعض وسائل الاعلام هذا الامر او
مراكز استطلاع الرايه احيانا واحيانا ايضا
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات نفسها ترفع
الحظر قبل الساعه التاسعه وفي وقت سابق
كان رئيسها قد توقع بان يتم الحسم هذه
النتائج واعلانها في في وقت مبكر بمعنى ان
النتائج لن تطول حتى ساعات متاخره من
الليل هذا بحسب التوقعات الاوليه للهيئه
العليا للانتخابات اخيرا انقر يوجد فيها
حوالي 4 مليون ناخب المره الماضيه شارك
فيها 91% صوتت لصالح كل جدار اوغلو وايضا
في هذه الجوله الانتخابيه يوجد حوالي 50
الف شخص اضيفه لاعداد الناخبين عن الجوله
الاولى وهم الذين بلغوا الثامن عشر خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين الاسبوعين الماضيين
الفاصلين بين الجوله الاولى والثانيه
وسيله